he's JC Treader he's the NFL Players
Association president and he is the
starting center for the Cleveland Browns
let's get to the important stuff right
away JC thanks for joining us how much
do you think the Commissioner ways yeah
I feel like I'm in one of the carnival
positions of trying to guess birthday
astrological sign and wait here yeah I
would say probably what like six to like
give him about 220 220 ok look like he
lost a little weight during the pandemic
but you could bench the commissioner
right yeah okay all right that's all I
wanted to know JC we appreciate you
joining us here hey by the way I got one
of the guys on my staff he went to
Dartmouth and he yeah you went to
Cornell
McLovin you want a shot at JC here no I
mean it's a shame II couldn't get in
Dartmouth I was curious was he a hotel
manager major or agriculture because I
was an English literature major
industrial labor relations forget it
okay could could you get into Dartmouth
Oh JC I believe so okay
also Dartmouth was your safe school yeah
yeah that was my fallback just in case
thing but really bad yeah all right
you know the Texans and Cowboys test
positive including Zeke Elliot yesterday
and it felt like the NFL when we
contacted them they don't really have a
plan in place if this happened during
this season what have you been told or
what are you telling your players about
this safe you know safety guidelines
that you're gonna have once the season
starts yeah I think that's that's why we
continue to work on it and I think this
is just a perfect example of you know
bringing back to light that this is
still going on and the world has gone
somewhat back to normal and places are
opening up but but this is still kind of
out there and you know what we've been
doing as a union it's just continue to
grind away at protocols and rules and
guidelines that we need to put in place
to make sure our players are as safe as
possible and then go back I think you
see that you know football players are
immune to this virus and we're not all
in perfect health I think people look at
us like we're kind of robots or
invincible but we have players in the
league with underlying conditions that
put them at higher risk of some really
negative results of this virus and not
only that but they have family members
who immunocompromised or have underlying
conditions that make them susceptible to
this virus so that all goes into play in
trying to figure out the best way to
keep everybody safe and healthy
throughout this year the players
association comfortable giving up all
this medical information you know if if
you're I'm assuming you know like the
NBA players have to get up give up this
medical information or the NFL players
you're gonna have to do the same thing
yeah we're looking through all that and
kind of you know what are the ethics
around all these issues and we've got
task forces looking into you know what
needs to be shared you know what are the
players choices and just trying to
figure out you know what what can we
talk about what can we share and figure
out the best way so we've had several
task force's looking at a bunch of
different avenues of kind of return to
play
we've got looking at risk mitigation
testing so we've had that going on for
the last two months now continuing to
look at different things that we can do
to keep people safe and trying to break
it up into each Avenue as we you know
approach our normal start to its season
do you think we're starting on time
that's a tough question and I think it's
tough because you see how how quickly
things can change
you kind of look we're about what six
weeks month and a half away from our
normal training camp start date and you
look back to what things look like a
month and a half ago and then a month
and a half before that and you see how
much how much different things look in
just six weeks so I think it's
irresponsible to speak in any definites
that far in advance
I think we've continued to look in short
intermediate like two-week bursts and
and we've got the virtual offseason that
we negotiate it's been extended till
June 26 so our guys know what they need
to do and what they're responsible for
until then some teams have begun closing
down and
or to a programmer released so guys have
gone onto their break like they normally
would but but our guys know at least for
the next two weeks what they can do and
then from there we have to continue to
work and continue to keep these guys
prepared and safe
he's JC Treader he's the NFL Players
Association president and the Cleveland
Browns Center how much dialogue has come
up with in the player association about
Colin Kaepernick I think this whole that
all the issues and it's been going on
for four years now is a constant
conversation it's been going on in
locker rooms and then at a union level I
mean that's why when the NFL tried to
unilaterally impose new rules and
guidelines it's why we filed a grievance
to fight that because we're not gonna
allow you know people to infringe on our
players rights so it's been something we
continue to fight for and Kyle and I
think I think it should be clear to
everybody by now he's out of the league
not because of a football issue and not
because he's not capable of playing
football so you know we hope and we
continue to push for him to be back and
brought back into the fold and be signed
by a team and we hope that happens but
you also have these now your quarterback
Baker Mayfield and JJ Watt Bill O'Brien
of the Texans they're saying they're
gonna take a knee can you I know it's
fast forwarding into September but what
are the sidelines gonna look like what
do you think the sidelines are gonna
look like I don't know but I think
luckily this conversation has continued
and at least people are starting to
understand that no one who was kneeling
before was it about anything with the
military no one no one said anything
about that
it was always fairly clear when you
asked him the question of why are you
kneeling they talked about the systemic
racism police brutality and racism in
the country and that and that's why they
were bringing awareness and I think
people have started to understand that
more and that's become a more widespread
understanding and you see the people now
becoming more comfortable while talking
to that issue and I think it's great
about guys raising awareness or issues
that passionate about and that's
something as players it's promoted we
have a week every year for my cause my
cleats where we go and get shoes and and
the media talks about all these stories
and all these issues that were
passionate about want to bring awareness
to and this is another issue guys want
to bring awareness to and it shouldn't
be don't talk about that issue know this
if this is an issue guys are passionate
about guys should be able to bring
awareness to that issue and I think it's
Justin Jackson from the Broncos who came
out and said you know we we wanted to
raise awareness for this back with
Kaepernick and we've raised awareness
maybe you don't need to try to do that
with the anthem that is there another
way like if you graduated from that to
something else you know for the lack of
a better description here for the entire
NFL Players Association is there another
level to this because you got eyes on
you
Kaepernick got eyes on him Malcolm
Jenkins Eric Reid some of these other
players now where do you go from here I
guess would be my question for anybody
involved in this yeah I think that's
those are conversations that are going
on in trying to segue that awareness
into action and into change and that's
kind of been the goal of raising the
awareness getting the eyes on it and
then segwaying that into tangible things
that can make make these issues better
and I think we're starting to see that
the players coalition has been very
active and I think teams are starting to
get behind that almost every team I've
talked to the players have said they've
had team meetings third throughout this
offseason dedicated to these issues
we've had in Cleveland we've had guest
speakers come in who are very involved
in these issues to share their knowledge
and their perspective so I think people
are starting to get more involved and
not just raising the awareness but
effecting change in communities and
that's a great thing to see his initials
JC stand for just cash JC Treader well
if you said the if I didn't watch the
Browns last year and I said what
happened how would you describe what
happened with the Browns last year yeah
I think we had a lot of a lot of
different directions being pulled at and
I think what's been nice with the
addition of Coach Stefanski coming to
the fold is there's a singular focus on
the work that has to go into it and
no worry about what expectations we have
or what people think we're capable of or
not capable of it's solely about
everyday putting the work in and I think
that's a change that was needed to be
able to come in and have everybody just
focused on getting better every day and
not worry about everything that's going
on on the outside not getting involved
with everything going on in the media
and just focused on playing football
playing at a high level Baker Mayfield
says he's not talking this year how long
is that gonna last JC I think Baker's
been great this offseason
I think he's been a true leader of the
team he's been great during the virtual
program and again you just see him
continue to take steps to establish
himself as you know the face of a
franchise and and a leader in the locker
room and he's been the leader since he
got here and and he continues to mature
and you know take that role and move
forward with it
but he's been great he's been going into
different meetings and being involved
beyond what what you'd expect but do you
think that he could actually be quiet uh
I mean yeah so far nobody unplayed yet
he hadn't been criticized for anything
yet oh that's true that's true I trust
you know his perspective at this point I
just want to go out there and prove it
on the field and I think whenever Baker
gets that chip on his shoulder you know
I'm excited to see what he can do yeah
did you ever just say shut up Baker well
Baker's one of those guys he's a chippy
guy where you know we go after each
other all the time just in fun but you
know he's one of the best guys in a
locker room where he likes giving it but
also he can he can take some criticism
and take some shots and not take it
personal so he's been he's been fun to
mess her our McLovin do you want to
place a bet Cornell
versus Dartmouth November 14th and you
know what put some something on the line
here I'm assuming Dartmouth will already
have wrapped up the Ivy League title by
then they might send some guys Wow
I don't know I mean Cornell Lhasa do
they really need their first team
against Cornell had on Jacy response
I mean I'm willing to you throughout the
wager I'm willing to listen I've been in
more contact with with my guys back at
Cornell recently and I'm excited to see
what they do how about um let me see how
about he has to wear a big green
Dartmouth Jersey in a post game of
whatever week that is like week ten he
has to wear a Dartmouth t-shirt in the
locker room room post game interviews
okay and I will wear a Cornell helmet
helmet on the show so he'll wear a
Dartmouth or a Cornell helmet for three
hours on the show J see you after that
sounds fair you have to wear Dartmouth
Jersey the entire week and you have to
bring up north Dartmouth that entire
following week you always have to make a
mention of Dartmouth Dartmouth football
Jay Fiedler buddy T Vin's all those is
that fair enough I have to I have to
wear this shirt for the entire week yes
I I think that's I think that's a little
a little too much I will I will wear it
for one day your choice whether it's
Sunday after the game or any day
throughout the week in any media that
week I will always give a reference to
Dartmouth
okay yes yes mclubbe don't negotiate
with me I'm not the NFL all right I
think we got it I think we got the the
battle lines have been drawn here now
all of a sudden I care about Dartmouth
and Cornell JC good luck in the
offseason with everything you're
navigating through we appreciate your
time
absolutely Thanks that's a JC Treader